i don't remember the year or the moment
exactly but i do remember thinking
what do i really believe in what
do i want the future to look like for
future generations
and it did not take me long to focus in
on the things that i truly believe in
are my faith and the other close second
was hillsdale college
[Music]
my route to hillsdale is a a bit of an
interesting one because while i was
i would definitely say it was one of if
not the best decisions of my life
it was one of those that i made
unlike me without a lot of angst
and overthinking i majored in
english the greatest growth i
experienced while i was on campus
was definitely in the area of confidence
confidence is something that i think i
struggled with
as one of six kids in a family are
always trying to figure out who you are
and
where you fit in so this was the first
thing that
i had chosen to do that was different
than anyone else in my family had chosen
to do i was paving my own path
and at first i felt tentative about that
and by the time i got to
my senior year i felt confident about
who i was what my strengths were
quite frankly what my weaknesses were
but also i knew that i could forge my
own path
i felt confident i could go from there
to a new environment in my postgraduate
life
and be successful as well i started my
career with
the chicago bulls as an intern and
the rest is history
having grown up in newport michigan
which is a
small town my entry into chicago was
a bit overwhelming the city felt massive
to me i had to figure things out by
myself sink or swim
and i learned by trial and error and i
kept feeling that confidence that i
started to bill at hillsdale grove
we knew at that time going into the 96
97 season still had michael jordan
scottie pippen dennis rodman we knew we
were going to win a championship
we didn't say that but we knew my first
day with the chicago bulls remember
sitting down
with the head of the pr department and
he said there's a
big party going on here and you are part
of it and it's exciting
but you'll be parking the cars outside
and every day of my career i've
remembered that because
it reminds me every day to know your
role
and play that role as best as you
possibly can
[Music]
so fast forward several years and i'm in
my fifth year
with the chicago marathon doing pr and
as luck or miss fortune would have it
the weather on the day of the marathon
was
oppressively hot and we knew it was
going to be a bad day
we canceled at midstream due to mostly
the health of the back
of the pack the next year of my life as
a result of that was
personally and professionally very
painful because we were under a ton
of media criticism my phone rang
non-stop every day all day for
months and it completely changed my
perspective quite frankly i became very
burned out
from working with the media as a result
of that and what i've realized is when
you are in moments of pain
you are growing i was introduced to
working with an organization called
octagon
sports marketing and knew that if anyone
was going to take a chance
on converting a pr person to a marketing
person it would be the people that i met
at octagon and they did they offered me
the opportunity and i have been with
them for the last 10 years
what's really enticed me to maintain a
career in sports for as long as i have
is that team environment i realize i am
at my best
when i'm surrounded by other people who
are really intelligent
and very talented and very skilled and i
know i have a role to play at that table
and so being part of that team that
achieves something remarkable
is is the personal thrill i get from
working in this industry
one of the things i always wanted to be
part of was
giving back to my communities and
organizations that i care about
i had been volunteering with the college
probably from near on the moment that i
graduated
i believe in its mission now more than i
did even when i was on campus and
and i believed in it then and at one
point
i remember gregor haystead who was the
head of alumni relations at the time
said would you ever consider joining the
alumni board
and my response was would the alumni
board ever consider
allowing me membership of course
and i'm finishing up my eighth year of
service on the board and i've
enjoyed it immensely you know once i
got onto the board we looked at new ways
to get
alumni involved on campus for the two
years that i was president
it felt very much like any other
consulting meeting i would go into with
a client
and i'm a problem solver so i'm looking
at college objectives and saying here
are the 10 things i think we can achieve
and help you with over the next 10 years
it furthers my belief that
things all come together at the right
time i think i was the
the right person at that time to be
sitting at the table
and talking about how we could shift and
change and mold the board's role
probably the most beautiful part of the
board is a
very familiar feel of family similar to
debates that you might have on campus we
have those debates in the boardroom
at the end of the day we all still have
such an amazing time together
it reinvigorated my relationships
through the college you would think that
we've been
friends for decades it's it's one of
my favorite ways to spend my free time